hello I'm Alexander Rose the executive
director at the long now foundation a
long time ago actually not that long ago
now I guess but one of our fellows
Stuart candy proposed this idea who's
here today I swear Stuart waiver had
there Stuart proposed this idea of doing
what's what he called long shorts so
short movies about cool long term
projects they kind of get the idea
across and a few months ago to Austrian
guys I'd never heard of sent some
photographs into to the Rosetta project
actually I think through Laura welter of
a project that they did in Hawaii and it
was by far one of the one of the coolest
long now inspired project side I had
seen and so I asked them to make a the
first of the long shorts and so we're
gonna try and show them before some of
these talks this is a five minute video
it's by white elephant studios Tobias
Tobias
Estel and Florian pushman and Tobias is
here tonight and I'll start the video
and he came out all the way from
Australia for that little applause Thank
You Austria sorry
[Applause]
so I'm going to start the video and then
Stuart will introduce Arthur Ganson and
enjoy your evening
[Music]
for the Austrian based designers to be
asked astal and Florian Bushmen of white
elephant design lab the experimentation
and exploration of materials and their
excitability by external influences is
an important resource of inspiration in
our work we often set the preconditions
for what will happen and we just let
materials intact next to quite
traditional tactics in product design
our work also deals with a more holistic
approach of form finding they are
fascinated by natural phenomena and the
potential of the qualities of material
[Music]
having studied the lava metier and how
it advanced the smooth and shiny surface
it had I thought what if we tried to
think of a way to shape and form it as
the two designers did more and more
research it became clear that they had
to go to Big Island of Hawaii the
islands Kilauea volcano is the most
active volcano on earth and surface
flows of the smooth before hyped lava
occur quite frequently during their four
weeks stay on Big Island in February
2009 long and exhausting hikes were
needed to reach the area of active
surface flows a rugged terrain sheer
endless oceans have solidified abrasive
lava rock I thought there's that massive
amount of energy in life it's a very
calm and peaceful situation they knew it
was necessary to bring special
protective gear in order to be able to
get really close to the hot lava and to
work with it they obtained protective
suits that are used in the steel
industry
discovering the reality of the actual
setting the view on the whole project
and their approach was changed
fundamentally this new ethical framework
we applied changed the way we work
completely we even cut back some of the
projects because we felt they were not
really appropriate to that specific
sacred area we found there
[Music]
[Music]
the project zero 2009 was one of the
major works carried out by Tobias
Kessler and Florian Bushman on Big
Island of Hawaii volcanic activities
have been going on since billions of
years on this planet placing this symbol
of long-term thinking in this context
seemed to be just the right thing the Oh
in front of the 2009 refers to the long
now foundation and indicates in a quite
strong powerful way that there's a lot
more time to spend and to plan for than
just the next decades
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
this place represents the past present
at the future it's about destruction and
creation at the same time
working on liquid rockets may be the
most fundamental thing for a designer I
think you won't get any closer to the
matter
[Music]
that reminds me of going to the movies
when I was young there was a short
subject before the main feature next
we'll have cartoons and newsreels redo
the whole thing imagine how pleased
archeologists of the future will be when
there's date stamps on that very
stratigraphic later the long now clock
ten thousand year o'clock we're building
in one mountain and then another
mountain is a work of kinetic art and as
such not only are we paying attention to
her ologist people have been designing
clocks for a long time but to a lot of
other artists who work with mechanical
things you can see one on the right-hand
side of the stage Arthur Ganson has been
at it for thirty years he's very very
adept now only do the things work well
and present well they inspire thoughts
well so he feared to tell it tell us
about it tonight Arthur Ganson
hello
all right thank you very much it's
really a pleasure to be here
and it's always a little daunting to
come up onto a stage and talk about the
work because really I make this work
because I am most comfortable like
isolating myself in my studio and if you
can imagine I'm sure there are a lot of
people in the audience who are like that
and you know what that is to be in your
solitaire space and and to work so it's
it's a little strange to take some of
the thoughts and to translate them into
words but I'm going to do my best
and I'll see if I can make some sense
out of things Thank You Stuart for
inviting me I really appreciate it Thank
You Alexander and everybody else in the
foundation who's been so wonderful and
helping to set this up I really
appreciate it
the what I'm going to do is I'm going to
give you a sense of how I work I'm going
to talk about many different pieces I'm
going to see if I can thread this idea
of time through the work time is a is a
is always a critical component for me
and sometimes I think about time in a
very conscious way where time itself
becomes part of the subject of the piece
and sometimes I don't at all where time
is just naturally
behind the scenes the we decided to call
the talk machines and the breath of time
and I've been thinking a lot about what
what that means and what it could mean
and I think the most important way for
me to think about that is that that just
as we breathe and I've been doing yoga
lately and I've learned that in in my
practice my breath is the continuity
through everything it's it's basically
the the underlying force of continuity
if I can always come to the breath and
the breath is essential and the breath
is always bringing me back to the
present moment
I think the time itself is like a breath
for these machines because they can't
exist without the passage of time they
can exist as physical objects but really
when I when I came to make sculpture
without really thinking about it I found
myself creating pieces that moved and I
think for for some reason I was just not
interested in in really just a physical
object itself but in the object as it be
as it is in the state of becoming as
it's changing and so so this this notion
of breath and time is is always there in
the background and I'll talk about it in
different ways a few things I want to
say about the work and about
understanding the work is that I'll give
you some of my thoughts about it but I
have a very strong feeling that that the
in order for the for the piece to have
any true meaning for anyone they bring
they they they create the meaning so if
you if you feel a connection with
anything it's it's it's not really in
the piece but it's really in you and
it's all about your own experience
that what you're bringing to it and it's
it's it's inseparable so I think I think
a lot about the fact that these machines
come from a place deep within myself and
they they I I kind of wrestled them into
being into a physicality they start in a
very non-physical way and they started
as an idea they started as a feeling
they started as a question and and
there's always a real like wrestling
I think wrestling is a good word of like
how to how to bring this into some sort
of a physical manifestation and then
it's here like this thinking chairs here
is a physical thing but you're observing
it and you all of your thoughts about it
everything you feel about it is true
it's irrelevant what what I feel about
it at that point and if if we talk about
this feeling of the long now which I
love thinking about this concept the I
think the machines start in an eternal
place and then they're in a physical
place which is just really temporary and
it's only a matter of time before these
will break but I have this feeling that
that where they are when they're
perceived and they're taken in to
someone's consciousness to their to
their spirit or to their heart then that
feels like it's an eternal place and
that's really a way of thinking about
the long now for me so when you leave
here forget everything that I say
because because really any words that I
have about them are kind of irrelevant
and the most important thing would be
your direct experience of it so I want
to talk a little bit about this thinking
chair piece because I wanted to bring
this this this physical object the
[Music]
the thinking chair occurred to me
there's a place near my studio in the
woods that I find myself going to and
walking and I've done this for many
years where I'll just go to a particular
rock outcropping and I find myself like
walking in circles on this particular
rock outcropping it's a very meditative
thing to do and then I found out that
there's actually many traditions that
use walking in circles as a form of
meditation but I was doing this
naturally and one one day I found a
stone that was sort of on the side of
this rock outcropping and I just had the
thought that I wanted to make this self
portrait this thinking chair and I think
actually the title is not very good I
think I'm gonna change the title at some
point if you can do that after the fact
because because really it's not so much
it's not so much a thinking chair but
it's more kind of being a chair that's
that's what I feel or a feeling chair so
the the chair is going to be in on the
side and it's going to be walking in
circles and it will be kind of like a
clock for this talk is kind of like a
mantra a circular mantra for for this
experience
the I'm just going through some notes
here so I'm going to take you back to
how I started to make these machines and
I'll take you first back way before I
made any machines and I had the impulse
to want to to make moving things the
first thing that I did when I was
probably in in like fifth or sixth grade
was I made animated movies and I would
draw them on the edge of books and I
have one of them here now we just we
just discovered that the screen
is not showing part of the bottom and
part of the right so I hope that you can
actually see the movie but this is this
is a little animation that I called the
Great Race and I remember drawing this I
remember that what was in my mind in
that moment was that there were these
two cars that were gonna run down the
road and there was a boulder in the road
and and all I wanted to do was I wanted
to imagine how the cars once they hit
the boulder would begin to flip over and
turn over and how the how the drivers in
the cars would be flown out of the cars
and there's a lot of violence of course
because when you're a kid you're totally
into violence so I'm going to show I'm
going to play this let's just see how
this goes I hope you can see it
so then there's the rock and I remember
drawing this I remember clearly
you see there's a lot of
[Applause]
and if now here's more gratuitous
violence so there's like an ambulance
coming crazy
so when I first started when I first
started to make oh boy we're losing well
you can imagine Madeline's fragile
machine okay when I first started to
make physical objects the it was in in
in late high school and I have to say I
was I was drawn to work with my hands
because I was so painfully shy that I
was not able to really talk to people I
mean I could talk a little bit but
really about what I was feeling in my
heart I was terrified of sharing what I
was feeling and I found that a way that
I could compensate or get around or to
express myself is that I would make
things for my friends and for people I
cared about and when I think back on it
now it was it was all I could do to tell
people that I love them by making things
so I'm telling you this because it's
sort of the umbrella on which under
which all of this work exists because it
was the foundational impulse for me to
start to make anything and it's always
there it's always in the background of
wanting to express really what's in my
heart and just very briefly it's it's
kind of odd that I came to make machines
because in in in high school I I was in
love with two subjects biology because I
had a wonderful biology teacher mr. daga
leo who changed my life in ways that I'm
just now discovering and also I spent my
senior year in high school programming
computers I was completely obsessed with
programming basic and I just like wrote
computer programs all day long it's
totally obsessed with it so
there's a part of me that loves that
wonderful sort of logical flow of
programming and I think also because I
was in so in love with biology and
working with my hands that was another
aspect of me and when I went to college
I had no idea what I would do so I came
into college actually in the pre-med
program imagining that I would go into
medical school and become a surgeon
because I just had this sort of very
naive dream that I that I would love to
do surgery and I think maybe in one
sense I could have done surgery if that
it was just doing surgery but there were
so much else that I had to deal with in
terms of information to memorize and I
mean I loved a lot of the courses in
pre-med but there were but my brain
cannot remember information so surgery
in med school started to look dim but at
the same time of taking art courses and
I started to fall in love with just the
hours and hours of drawing and that sort
of meditative state of being with with
the drawing so accidentally in in my
sophomore year just responding to to
some project that I was given and my
school UNH in New Hampshire was very
traditional art art program I didn't go
because of the aura program but it has a
very good art program I was doing bronze
casting and oil painting and printmaking
and for some reason I was given some 3d
design project and I started I I started
to solder up a few little pieces of wire
and I made a little gear and just a very
simple little mechanism because I knew
how to solder because I hadn't made a
heath kit which is like a little
electronics tool right so I sort of knew
that oh I'll just put something together
and all of a sudden this this this whole
world opened up and I didn't know it at
that point but I can look back and I can
see what was happening
that that I started to make these these
very fragile and I'm gonna I'm gonna run
this because this is not this is not an
early piece a lot of those early pieces
have fallen apart cuz they were tin-lead
solder but but this is very akin to what
I was doing when I first started to work
with wire so I found myself making these
very complex mechanisms and part of the
challenge of making these was the
physical challenge of holding the pieces
of wire in space as I soldered them and
as the wire was getting hot because I
was using a tin lead solder he's
starting to burn my fingers and and it
was very much a physical challenge to
see if I could actually build these
things so this was this was me doing my
surgery I created a little world in
which I could be a surgeon and because I
was creating these mechanisms in the
space I think that that was the part of
me that wanted to be a computer
programmer I could take all of that
logical cause-and-effect that was that
that always felt a little bit dry
because it was just in code and I could
do all of that in in 3d space and it
felt it felt visceral
and and then working with wire it became
line in space I'm drawing in space so I
could I could take all of my feelings
and put them into these little fragile
machines
so that's that's how these started with
me and I've never studied engineering in
any formal way it's just been 30 years
of making a mistake every time but
slowly learning slowly learning through
intuition about how things move and how
things feel when they move but the
impulse for me to work has always been
to follow the feeling of the piece I
I've always been driven to one of
expressed express a feeling
Thanks
and in many ways those those fragile
machines they're they're like as close
to oil painting as I can get because
those those pieces like that that
machine evolved it just grew and it's
it's it's very much about plant growth
now this is a fairly early piece I
called it the busyness man it's kind of
about this frenzied feeling of time this
this little man has a long he's in his
lawn now of friends eNOS so he's a
little plastic figure he's about like
three inches tall
and I remember designing this piece I
started with the man I kind of a general
framework I didn't think about how the
mechanism would have to be designed
beforehand and I gave myself the problem
the challenge of having a hand crank
that would only turn in one direction
and I had to solve all of the problems
of making him walk back and forth by
having a crank in one direction and
those initial conditions led to that
piece and there's nothing in these
machines that's that's that is
superfluous all of the parts are there
for a mechanical functional reason but
of course I have great latitude with how
I use the water
but everything is there for a product
for a true functional
now there's a piece of knotted string
there now this this this machine was
done maybe about 15 15 years ago and I
graduated from just 10 LED soldering III
learn very slowly it's like I evolved
very slowly like all of the first
machines they were all put together with
tin-lead solder Electrical solder and
any any joints that were under stress
ultimately just broke so now basically
what I'm doing is I'm spot welding the
wire and silver soldering the wire
so here's in contrast here's a very
simple machine that is called machine
with Chinese fan and really just I was
just imagining what is the what just
just opening a Chinese fan what does it
feel like and I wanted to I wanted to
make the machine
it's um I'm gonna stop this for one
second there there's I think a lot about
this edge between clarity and ambiguity
and I think that there's a there's a
golden very important place when when
when we're working in the arts to that
if if if the object is is crystal clear
and completely ambiguous at the same
time I think that is the condition that
allows a viewer to both comprehend it
and not understand it and and then and
then naturally to make sense you're
going to create your own story with it
if it's too clear then there's not
enough to dream with and I think if it's
too ambiguous then maybe there's not
enough to dream with so there is kind of
a fine line that I try to hit and now
this this piece
really started off as a very simple toy
we sometimes the pieces I feel like they
give me back more than I put in and I I
was just I was just playing with the
wishbone after dinner one day imagining
that this was a cowboy who had been on
his horse for too long now I want you to
forget all of that because then that
just like distorts here but but that's
really how this happened you know it's
just been a very playful way just taking
the wishbone and walking it across the
table and I thought well I could just
make a little machine that would that
would cause the wishbone to move in that
manner and then if the machine itself
was just on wheels than the wishbone
could drag its machine so it becomes a
kind of a confusing
it's a little bit of a paradox now once
I once I got the Machine done
I feel like I feel like because the
wishbone is is is part animal then that
of course that's of course where we
enter and I feel like of course all of
these machines are self-portraits and so
I feel like that is me and very much I I
always feel like that but I'm but I'm
learning I'm slowly I'm I'm slowly
learning okay
machine with concrete this this piece
I've made a number of versions of and
the the first piece came to me I
remember the moment I was walking by the
GSD at Harvard University and I just had
this thought it was kind of a
mathematical playful thought that I
could take a series of reduction gears
and if I made the reduction sufficient
enough then then I could I could create
a kind of a strange situation and I was
imagining that that if if I took a
series of worm reductions and if I took
a reduction of one-fiftieth and and then
started to stack one-fiftieth upon
one-fiftieth then I could come up with a
machine where one end would move so
slowly that it might as well be fixed
and not moving at all and I remember the
first the first manifestation of the
piece I made out of wire and it didn't
express the idea at all I was just
working out I was I was caught in the I
was caught in the math of it and I
wasn't really feeling it and I made like
a little spiral tower with these wire
gears that I make you turn the little
bottom crank and it was the same
principle and the top top gears were
actually soldered in place but nobody
knew it you couldn't see it so it didn't
it didn't really convey the feeling so
after that I rien visioned and I
realized oh I have to use substantial
gears I have to use real real materials
that you can that you can get a feeling
sense for so I made this piece machines
with concrete now what you see there
there's the last year that's embedded in
concrete and this is a series of of 1252
one reductions the motor is turning at
212 revolutions a minute now we're gonna
pan across and so the first ones turning
150th of that and then the next one is
150th of that and 150th of that and
before too long it's moving so slowly
that it will take the last year it'll
take that last gear 2.19 one trillion
years to turn
so you get to that point you can do
anything is that considered along now I
I don't know so so I embedded it in
concrete and I thought about many
manifestations and versions of this and
I've made just two others but one one
piece that I I have yet to make that I
really want to do is to is to have the
machine that the mechanism trailing off
and then the mechanism is actually looks
like it's been melted off the pedestal
so you have a working machine on one end
and then you have the melted machine on
the other
I was I was then asked to make another
version for a museum in Germany and so I
made this next version which I don't
have video of but you can get a sense I
used these spur gears and I oriented
them at a slight angle and the
difference with with this version is
that the large gear and you're gonna see
an image the large gear there is is
actually cut through the block of cement
so it's very clear clearly it's not
going to move in this case there are
many more gears and I forgot what the
exact ratio of that one is but then I
was just recently invited to be a part
of a show in Austria and they really
wanted to to show the machine with
concrete and I wanted to make another
one and to to actually think more about
what the final reduction would be
because with the first two I I had
created the machine but hadn't really
contemplated how slow it should go and
what what's it about and I decided that
a nice target point would be the Big
Bang
which people
some scientists imagine is 13.7 give or
take a few billion years but 13.7
billion years that's what I've read so I
I made the next machine and
unfortunately I don't have video of this
one either but that's what it looks like
this is like so awful to just have this
moving machine but just but just so a
picture of it and I'm showing you a
picture because I'm showing you a
picture because sometimes or very often
the subtitle for my work is machines in
the nick of time and I had to get this
piece sent off to the show and I
literally got it done and into the crate
the moment that the shipper was arriving
and I was going crazy it's like what I
don't even have time to take a picture
of it or take any video and then it went
away and this image was actually shot by
the people at the show but the last gear
which is embedded in that block is will
turn once every 13 very closely once
every 13.7 billion years and I decided
that this one I would title be holding
the big bang because it feels it feels
very much like I'm looking back to that
point and as I think about these
machines it's not it's not about the
math and it's not about the ratios it's
for me it's it's about the feeling of
the intense activity that's going on on
the left and the very they're very quiet
stillness that's happening on the right
excuse me
and it's very much about this duality
then I feel actually in my own being
which is which is beholding my own
action my own activity my own frenzied
activity my own drive and desire to move
excuse me and and the other part of me
which feels timeless and very quiet and
very still so I think that that for me
this is this is where I was what I was
trying to get at in the making of these
pieces is to somehow make a somehow
envision this this duality that I sort
of feel in my own being in many ways
it's in a very strange way it's kind of
a deep a deep self-portrait in that
sense thank you
so this next piece in thinking about
time this next piece I titled it Corey's
yellow chair Corey's my son and he had
from a long time he had a little yellow
chair in my studio
I'll just police gonna run through this
piece
it's a very short sequence
so when I when I first imagined this
piece I looked at Cory's chair and I saw
it explode in my mind and I saw it
exploding up and out I first actually
imagined the piece on a pedestal and I
imagined the life-sized chair and I
imagine this this life-sized chair
exploding up and out into 12 pieces and
the only important thing here is that
the gesture with which the imagination
was that it felt very clear that the
explosion was instantaneous and the
moment that the chair exploded the
pieces were moving at infinite speed
flying away and somehow with the force
of some sort of gravity these pieces
that flew away from the center point
would would slow down and a kind of
gravitational force would would bring
them back to the center they would reach
a point of stillness at the far extreme
of their period and then begin to
coalesce and to condense into forming a
chair again approaching infinite speed
the moment that the chair is in
existence and it's there for just a
moment and then it's gone so I can very
clearly imagine all of these things in
my mind I can imagine I can see the
pieces moving with with infinite speed
and stopping instantaneously but of
course you can't do this in the physical
world so when I had the the thought to
make this piece already I knew that it
was just going to be a very weak stab at
this idea that that that all I could do
would be to to just suggest what what
the true feeling was because there'd be
no way I could really build it
truthfully and then there was a lot of
development I said it started off as an
imagination with 12 pieces exploding up
and out and that gradually worked down
to six pieces
I changed the orientation of the way I
was first imagining a machine and
ultimately came up with with that
version now some of you have seen the
actual piece but that piece that you
just saw the chair is only this big it's
about four inches tall and it's
exploding to about four feet and I did
make another larger version which is
also in a museum in Germany right now
but really really the essence for me I I
found well what was driving that piece
was was was a question of of of when is
now like when is now and a in very often
at the beginning of a Buddhist Dharma
talk the teacher will will clap their
clap his or her hands and that moment of
the clapping is kind of a signal of the
now moment
and I I think I was I was reaching for
that in the moment that the chair was
coalescing asking when is now and just
and and and and I wanted the chair to be
there for just an instant because the
now feels so fleeting it's just gone
it's here and it's gone this this next
series of pieces came as a result of of
meeting someone in Boston who was part
of a movement theatre company and
together we created a piece called
shadow of a doubt which which was a play
that involved real people and large
machines onstage in a drama that the the
subject of the drama was a guy who was a
kind of a tormented invent
like nobody I know a tormented inventor
slash investigator and anyway I just to
give you some sense because I'm going to
show you a machine called a
knife-throwing machine but the the I
wanted to talk about the the notion of
the play which which was very much also
about thinking about this moment of now
that we had this feeling that that if we
if we think about all of the activities
of life as a kind of mechanism that in
which we are a part of and there are
there were so many chance events so many
moments that have brought everybody in
this room together here in this moment
now we're sharing this moment and after
the talk is over we're gonna disperse
and we'll go about our lives and there's
there's a feeling that that it's kind of
like an hourglass feeling where if you
were to think about all of our lives
coming to this point this shared moment
this common moment and then dispersing
so of course there are an infinite
number of these moments happening all
the time but we had this feeling that
this could be kind of the backbone for
this play and I made a series of large
machines that would would somehow
represent the fabric that was that was
in the background
this this machine here and I don't have
video of it was a very large it's about
this tall I called it the unfolding
machine and at one point in the play
this this machine would come out from
from stage right and it would it would
move very slowly out
and then the the arm on top would would
very slowly raise up and there was a
series of gears that were rhythmically
pulling it up and the arm would raise up
and then the machine began to fall and
it went through about a three or four
minute slow motion fall in space and I
have another image here which is the
machine in its downward it's it's almost
reached the ground now on the way right
you see there's a little extension
there's kind of a head there and when
the machine very gracefully came down to
the floor it released a crystal ball
that that rolled into the hands of this
tormented inventor who was sort of
sitting in front of it and that was that
was one focused moment in the play and
the next focused moment was that
throughout the entire duration of the
play this machine which is the letter
delivery machine now started off on
stage right at the beginning of the play
in the context of the play you know that
that the protagonist is to receive a
letter from his wife at the stroke of
midnight and everything is coming down
to this moment the stroke of midnight so
in the audience you can see the letter
on its way because this machine that
that that wheel that's off to the right
I'm sorry off to your left that that
foot would would very slowly get pushed
out and pulled in and pushed out and
every time it would do that that machine
would inch forward very slowly so we had
to choreograph this play around this
machine that was actually moving forward
during the whole production it's and but
you can see it working toward the place
in space and time where the letter is to
be delivered and that's the letter way
out in front so you can see you have
the anticipation oh yeah the letterers
reaching that point we are coming to the
to the point of midnight and on the
other side of the stage
Stage Left was the knife throwing
machine that at the beginning of the
play it cocked itself and it raised the
arm and it's holding a very substantial
piece of metal which is a real throwing
knife and it's pointed right at that
point where the letter is to be
delivered so it's all coming down and
there's a very strong feeling that these
that these machines are in cahoots and
that they're really after him or this is
fate somehow and basically what happened
was there was an intense flurry of
activity at the stroke of midnight and
right at the moment of midnight
suddenly there was silence and he's
there and he reaches for the letter he's
in the middle of a stage and he reaches
for the letter and the knife is trained
right at him just before he grabs a
letter it falls out of the head of a
letter delivering the chain to the floor
so he has to reach down to pick it off
the floor at that point the knife
machine it throws the knife over his
head into the wall right behind him
we were very careful we were very
careful because it really did throw this
this this knife now making this making
the knife filling machine was totally
crazy because because I had never made a
knife throwing machine before and it's
like I just got so like caught in the
idea how odd this is gonna be really
cool I had to do this but I'm telling
you it's like I just I imagined what I
would have to do to throw the knife and
I made the parts and I'm working down my
in my basement at this time and the
ceiling is this high right if I let it
go and the knife hits the ceiling and
like flies over the floor it's like oh
my god this is this is terrible and of
course the production in which this is
going to be in is like set in snow
because we because we've committed to
doing the play at a festival in Boston
so a little bit of anxiety there but it
was it was a wonderful learning journey
to to go to figure out to solve the
problem like how am I gonna get this
machine to throw this knife and I did
get it to throw it pretty accurately I
mean it would throw that knife 25 feet
across the stage and into the wall and
it was usually it would hit the same
exact spot so okay
was that usually let me see it's it's
8:20 okay okay
I just want to I'm gonna just this in a
way is another way of looking imagining
the passage of time
so this this piece came as I was playing
with a computer program that was
simulating objects in space and I was I
put together a very simple virtual
system and gave it the gravity of the
Moon and I had this piston moving up and
down and and having this object this
irregularly shaped object moving and I
was just fascinated with watching this
object move and I was so inspired that I
wanted to make a physical piece that
would express this feeling and the first
the first manifestation I was imagining
that I would take information off the
computer I'm always trying to use the
computer I really want to use a computer
in my work but I never seem to end up
doing it because I sort of like I just
like it pulled over to pure mechanics
but
there was there was a lot of evolution
in this piece in terms of imagining how
it should be built at first when I
imagined that I wanted to have a cat
that was moving back and forth I first
imagined the cat would have to sort of
move back and forth on the kind of
random way and I spent I spent a few
weeks building a very complex mechanism
that would make this cat go back and
forth and then after it was all done I
just thought this is like way to
visually noisy it's just awful
and then that was that was what told me
I had to actually have a very constant
cat back and forth that would then help
to express the irregularity the the
beautiful irregularity of the chair of
the chair and that disc in the back is
counter balancing that chair
and the chair is on an axle that goes
through the disk is on the same axle so
the mass of that disk is added to the
chair so the chair wants to move like
it's a larger object so it's a very
simple system a very true system that's
a dollhouse chair it's it's that it's
like four inch it's a little plastic cat
this is one of the pieces that I just
love to sit and watch because I'm always
like waiting for I sometimes sometimes
the conditions are right that it just
makes the most beautiful like triple
flip one direction and then the leg
catches just right and it makes another
beautiful flip the other direction but
it's totally unpredictable
is that a terrified cat or what
when I found that cat that was the
perfect cat so I have a few pieces here
that that are about sort of another way
of thinking about the machine that is
imagining imagining the sensuality of
the human being and expressing this with
a machine now I just have a very short
sequence of this this is the first one
of this series and I call this machine
with oil and all it's doing is just
bathing itself or the oil now this this
is the the second machine I was asked by
a friend at one point if I had a machine
she was in she wanted to have an
exhibition of erotic art and I didn't
have any pieces but this piece popped
into my mind this might called machine
with grease
and this this is probably about maybe
ten years old now this is a very recent
piece that I called my little violin and
[Music]
just imagining a simple relationship
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Laughter]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
this is simple a simple little parody
it's I like I like the piece because
it's good clean fun and you can show it
anywhere a completely different notion
and this is every now and then that did
this machine machine for softening
hardened hearts was it was a very this
was a very difficult piece for me to
make because I had the the thought of it
and it's it's really kind of about the
evolution of the soul and the evolution
of my soul and considering the
possibility that that there is no evil
and but that there's no evil but there
is spiritual sickness and and that if I
that whenever I look out and I see I see
evil then it's really my own heart that
I need to contend with I'm not
explaining this well but I'm going to
show you this piece it's very new and
I'm not really even sure how to talk
about it but I had this imagination that
there would be a machine
I used probably the archetypical symbol
of what we consider evil which is Hitler
and I wanted to make a machine I had the
idea of making a machine that would
caress his heart and I called the
machine machine for softening hardened
hearts with this notion that it would it
would be softening Hitler's heart but
the action of using the machine is is an
action to step forward and perhaps
soften my own heart in the process of
operating the machine when I had the
idea to make the machine I was repulsed
by it and I and I I wanted to do it but
it was really hard to actually build it
and I remember I went to the bookstore
looking for images of Hitler and I was
imagining putting it together and at one
point it was just I just thought no I
just don't want to do this but then I
kind of moved ahead and built it so I
don't pardon no no but it's it's a it's
not many people have actually seen that
piece yet and it's a very new piece and
I'm not even I'm not even I mean clearly
I'm not comfortable talking about it
because I'm not really sure how to talk
about it yet but that it came from they
came from an impulse in the need inside
to want to to create this experience
that how could i how can i caress his
heart how could I possibly do that but I
find that that operating the Machine
ends up being very much an opening
experience from my own heart which is
really about forgiveness and about
changing how we how we look as I said
changing how we look about at what what
is evil and what is sickness so thanks
thank you okay I have one more video to
show you and then we can go to some
questions and I like to show this piece
last because in many ways it feels like
the most complete piece for me it's it's
it's complete now in its video form the
it was imagined while I was doing the
play shadow of a doubt with those large
machines and I wanted to have a whole
machine theater evening where there were
no people on stage and there were no
play but there were these little
vignette moments with machines on stage
so I imagine this very simple gestural
dance with the machine in a chair and I
imagined it first to Spanish guitar
music where the machine would come out
from behind the curtain and there'd be a
loan a loan chair sitting in the center
of the stage and the Machine would
excuse me and the Machine would come out
and do its gestural dance when it was
this piece that use that you're gonna
see was exhibited only once for seven
weeks at my first sort of substantial
solo show at the de Cordova Museum in
Lincoln Mass after that seven weeks it
was like it was a real struggle to keep
it working so I ended up taking it all
apart but I did do a video document of
it there was no music when the piece was
shown because it would have driven
people crazy just in that space but with
video tape I was able to add the music
and it actually feels much more complete
now in this form and the music is is a
piece that I wrote when I was when also
when I was
very young I was playing guitar I spent
a lot of time by my saw blade has no
guitar so that was always a part of my
life and when I when I put the video
together I I took a short piece that I
had written for puppets and adapted it
to be the soundtrack for the dance so in
that way it feels like a very complete
piece because it's taking drawing from
all parts of me so I'm just going to let
this run it starts off with a time-lapse
of the installation of this piece in the
did at the corner of a museum made by a
guy named Mark Weisberg who was living
in Boston at the time and he made this
time-lapse little movie the installation
so you'll get a sense of the scale and
parts that was a real banquet chair you
see I could go on for days about the
mechanical problems of this piece but
I'll spare you
one thing that's kind of interesting is
that I did build this piece in my
basement with the ceiling of this tall
so it was a whole series of building
parts bringing it outside seeing how it
didn't work bringing it back down
rebuilding it but after many
[Music]
thank you thank you
thank you so much the so aside from
being the director of the foundation I'm
also the project manager on the ten
thousand year clock project and I know
we have one of the engineers chrisser
and is here of the clock project and one
of the things that we struggle with as
makers of things and actually I'd like a
show of hands how many how many makers
of things are here in the room tonight
yes Wow about 90 percent that's great
high concentration of maker Neuros
perfect yeah
is one of the things that we always
struggle with is tolerances and I think
that one of the beauties in your work
that you show is is actually how little
tolerances you need to achieve really
high degree of affect and it's it's a
pleasure to see you explaining it a
question from Kevin Kelly are you ever
attempted to make a machine that is
useful yes yes yeah and I've made I've
made a number of usable machines admit I
made quite a few useful machines also
the for me the real passion is to make
these machines that are nothing but
contemplation but I did spend actually
three years I came up with this idea for
a toy anybody hear of tubers and Zots so
some of you yeah well came up with this
idea that for this toy and there was no
way to make it and I ended up spending
like two and a half years in my studio
with a few other friends and making
production tools and it was it was an
incredibly exciting interesting three
years of developing these tools that
would work with foam and very soft
aluminum wire and
there were all there many steps to the
to the process of making this toy each
one had its own like myriad of problems
and it was such a juicy experience to
solve all these problems the the there's
there's such a commonality I mean
because I'm making I'm making machines
that have an ultimate ultimately have no
utilitarian function but everything
about them is utilitarian so I I share I
share everything with all engineers I
mean I'm I'm I have to obey the laws of
physics
I want these pieces to move to move and
to work so there is a certain amount of
rigor that has to be put into them and
many serious problems to solve to in
order to get this little piece to work
so really the the process of engineering
is the same for something utilitarian
and something like this max just max
apparently your machines display a sort
of education of the hands which is now
increasingly endangered this room
notwithstanding clearly how do you think
the solid-state circuitry and
miniaturization effects our relationship
with everyday machines as a whole and
losing shop classes and schools and
things like that did you have a shop
class yes I did yeah well I in in in
high school I had a shop class and I was
we were working with wood I didn't do
any metalworking I remember working a
lot on the lathe that's so but I don't
know I was always making stuff with my
hands as a little kid it was just as I
said it came for me it came as as a form
of personal expression
I actually didn't spend much time taking
apart things I was building things but I
was never really like I didn't take
apart clock sir
i I didn't approach it it did it didn't
come to me in that way but I can see how
how the the explosion of all things
digital is is a real inhibition because
you can do so many things with
processing that used to be done by
needing to understand systems in the
physical world I I think that maybe
maybe because there are less farmers I
mean maybe we need more farmers right
because when you're working on the land
and you have right
wasn't that the backbone of our capacity
to build and invent and it come from the
fact that we were actually like we had
stuff and we had to tend the land and we
had vision
yeah well that's I mean it's the same
reason we arrived on mechanics for the
clock right because yeah you knew yeah
you arrived and the electronic thing
isn't working there's no reverse
engineering it no reverse in the
mechanics are magical always what you
prove so well yeah do you usually
envision this is from Stephanie Carson
do you usually envision many or possibly
infinite solutions to the same problem
and choose among them or does does one
thing come to you from the beginning and
that's that's a that's a really good
question the very often the the piece
will will start as a as a feeling and I
have no idea really how to build it at
first
and it'll just need to it'll need to
percolate and I'll contemplate it for
quite a while before I have a sense
really of how to approach
the physicality of it that's that's
generally the case sometimes sometimes a
piece will be inspired by finding an
object and that will trigger a thought
and then maybe it's a clearer pathway
and in that case there's also a kind of
a connection with the world of puppetry
because the object is kind of like a
puppet and I'm a puppeteer and the first
step is to play with the object and then
to imagine the machine as the ultimate
puppeteer but very often they actually
have to sit with me for a while before I
have a sense because there are there are
so many possibilities and also the
building process is always like it's
always it's always teaching me because I
think with every piece I don't seem to
get any better at it where like I think
okay well this is how I'm gonna do it I
start building it and and then it's
clear oh no that's not gonna work or
that's that's not doing what I imagined
it would do maybe the thing that I'm
getting better at with experience is is
is knowing how to approach the building
process so I can solve the more global
problems initially because I think I
think when I when I first started to
make the machines I would get all
wrapped up in one little detail spend a
lot of time building it and then realize
way down the road that actually that's
like completely useless that's that's
that's not I can't I can't use that so
if I'm if I'm getting better at anything
which it's it's having like being able
to step back and to look at the the
overall and to ask what are the general
questions and one of the sort of general
tests and and
and and maquettes and models to make or
their first steps and sometimes the
machine can very naturally evolve from
from that point so because I think the
best the best machines evolve in a way
where somehow I'm not really even though
I'm making the decisions I'm not really
making the decisions that it's like well
once they get started
they can they can grow and develop in a
very natural way we have we have two
questions from someone named Chris but
they appear to be two different Chris's
no last names but they are related in
their related to last question the one
is how long do you spend on these is it
weeks months years and are there other
artists like you are there colleagues
that you talk with regularly is there a
is there a guild meeting that everyone
can go to I think is what I for me that
the pieces they're either either take
they either take a week maybe generally
a week is like the shortest time to
really get involved in something a few
weeks a few months maybe the longest
piece has been like a year and a half or
so when I when I made the large version
of the exploding chair for say no that
was probably about a year and a half but
that was only because I spent a half a
year trying to do it with servo motors
and decided no I have to do it
mechanically so the the range the range
of time is is completely completely
variable sometimes I like them to take a
lot of time though and this is something
I wanted to mention earlier in terms of
the the the time spent that like with
with with the wire machines it's I love
sitting there and building them I mean
it's it's it's
such a process of submitting to the
fabrication and to and to just enjoying
that process it's like it's like
knitting sometimes or just this working
with the hand it's just just spending
the time with my hands and with these
parts and so I think I think there's a
real satisfaction there's a real joy in
just in just being being with with that
sometimes the there's if the pieces do
somewhere that becomes a kind of
imposition and I have to I have to stop
it short
because maybe with most of these pieces
I would never stop building them I'm
sure a lot of you understand this where
you can can you can always get it better
you can always sort of refine it and
keep developing it for me sometimes the
pieces though they'll never never stop
and in terms of in terms of other
artists I mean there are there are so
many around I wouldn't say that I
there's a particular group that like
like a small group that I hang around
with but but I feel like there's there's
a fairly large network of people I mean
there's certainly a number of people in
Boston who are working lately I've been
somewhat secluded though so I'm not I'm
not regularly getting together with with
similar makers and I think that's
actually that's actually a problem
because I find that I that I can I can
be very isolated in in my working
process and every time I get together
with other people who are building I'm
always so inspired by by how they're
solving problems and what questions
they're asking so so
network is there and this question is
actually reminding me to plug more
deeply into it is anyone from Maker
Faire here tonight no the creator of
Maker Faire okay so is there no is there
an invitation for him to come out next
year
okay well long now presented there last
year and we had to explain our stuff all
day long and it it does great things
when you have to explain yourself all
day long
so we're fairly late so I'm going to
just cut it short to the one last
question that is the number one ask
question in the whole pile and bet
you're gonna guess what it is
what's with the chairs chairs chairs
yeah well the first the first chair was
the machine with chair the really large
one and then and then the next one was a
little exploding chair and and then I
the next one was was Margo's cat the
floating and then this one the chairs I
think that that without consciously
deciding that I was going to use chairs
for any particular reason I think that
that that we the chair is is kind of the
perfect object because we have a world
of knowledge in our bodies that we know
with our bodies week you know we know
with their minds but we also know with
our bodies and we know what a chair is
through the experience the physical
experience of interacting with it and I
think that that using the chair is
tapping into your visceral experience of
what a chair is and you bring all of
that to the creation of meaning when you
see the piece so I'm using them because
when I when I make a piece with a chair
very often it just feels right and after
thinking about it I think it's because
of that deep understanding that we have
in our bodies that that that gets
brought
and used to create the meaning so it's a
physical understanding well I've been a
admirer of your work for years and I
want to thank you for coming out and we
clearly need to cast part of our clock
in concrete my takeaway from tonight
thank you thank you
[Applause]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you